[Música]
cientos de pasajeros quedaron varados en
aeropuertos de Colombia y Perú luego de
que la aerolínea colombiana viva Air
suspendiera sus operaciones alegando
dificultades financieras la decisión
generó bloqueos y protestas en varias
terminales aéreas de Colombia
la fiscalía de Perú pide 36 meses de
prisión preventiva contra el ya
encarcelado ex presidente Pedro Castillo
la solicitud corresponde a un proceso
penal por delitos de organización
criminal colusión y tráfico de
influencias Tenemos reporte desde Lima
unas mil personas partieron de Tapachula
en la frontera sur de México rumbo a
Estados Unidos en la que sería la
primera gran caravana migrante del año
muchos de ellos cruzarán la República
Mexicana sin contar con la documentación
oficial
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en France 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz empezamos en
Colombia cientos de pasajeros quedaron
bloqueados luego de que la mayor
aerolínea de bajo costo de este país
suspendiera repentinamente sus
operaciones lo que provocó protestas y
bloqueos la compañía viva Air anunció en
un comunicado que suspendía la venta de
tiquetes de manera inmediata y dejaba en
tierra a toda su flota debido a sus
dificultades financieras nuestro
periodista Muñoz fue hasta el aeropuerto
El Dorado en la ciudad de Bogotá y nos
envió el siguiente reporte
situación dramática en Colombia la
compañía low cost suspendió su actividad
después de 11 años en el aire centenares
de pasajeros quedaron varados en
aeropuertos como este el del Dorado
internacional de Bogotá muchos pasajeros
también eran de otros países como
Antonio de Perú Así se siente
mortificado impotente porque yo estoy de
paso no tengo familias acá y a los están
reservados y y Los Soles no no abundan
para nosotros porque usted sabe que yo
soy jubilado y y hice todo un esfuerzo
de ahorrar para venir a a a a disfrutar
aquí de acá de Colombia pero me veo con
esa bendita sorpresa no sé qué hacer
viva él como único que paralizaba su
actividad debido a una situación
financiera crítica y también denunció
que después de meses no sabía aceptado
la oferta de Avianca para absorber el
grupo por su parte la aeronáutica civil
colombiana aseguraba que esta absorción
podría vulnerar las leyes de monopolio y
también denunció que viva Air no aceptó
otras ofertas de compañías chilenas como
Jet Smart o latam algunos usuarios como
Manuela habían comprado su tiquete horas
antes de la paralización
O sea a mí lo que me parece el descaro
es que permitan que la página hubiera
funcionado hasta el último minuto
permitieron que las personas compraran y
simplemente cerraron
Entonces ya estoy haciendo fila en esta
otra aerolínea a ver si me pueden
solucionar pero lo repito lo que no me
parece correcto es que hasta último
minuto dejaron la página habilitada para
que la gente siguiera comprando aún
ellos sabiendo que esto iba a suceder la
pasada semana ya había renunciado el
director de una compañía que mantiene 35
líneas nacionales en Colombia y varias
internacionales a Argentina Brasil y
Perú quedan en el Limbo 5000 empleos y
mientras algunos usuarios están siendo
recolocados en vuelos de Avianca satena
y latam otros se mantienen en la
incertidumbre a la espera de una
solución Mientras tanto también en el
aeropuerto Las publicidades todavía se
mantienen
Vamos hasta Perú la fiscalía solicitó 36
meses de prisión preventiva contra el ya
encarcelado expresidente Pedro Castillo
Álex mandatario se le habían dictado ya
18 meses de prisión preventiva mientras
es investigado por rebelión y
conspiración después del fallido golpe
de estado el año pasado los detalles nos
los entregaba previamente desde Lima
nuestro corresponsal Francisco Zacarías
es el nuevo pedido de la Fiscalía de 36
meses contra Pedro Castillo es por los
delitos de organización criminal tráfico
de influencias y colusión algunos
juristas con los que he conversado para
este reporte me afirman que si este
viernes la el poder judicial aprueba
este de nuevo requerimiento de la
fiscalía a partir del viernes se
comenzarán a contabilizar los 36 meses
de prisión preventiva y me afirman que
porque la legislación peruana es así
este nuevo requerimiento de 36 meses o
sea que es la medida de mayor duración
va a absolver a los 18 meses de
reclusión que fue ordenada anteriormente
contra Pedro Castillo por los delitos de
rebelión y conspiración que la justicia
peruana ordenó contraer en diciembre
pasado
y de Perú nos vamos a México porque
partió de la ciudad de Tapachula la
primera caravana de migrantes con rumbo
a Estados Unidos compuesta por miles de
personas provenientes de Venezuela y
países de Centroamérica y el Caribe su
sueño de llegar a territorio
estadounidense podría haberse frustrado
debido a la nueva política migratoria
del presidente Joe biden que ordena la
deportación inmediata de migrantes
irregulares que entren a su país por la
frontera con México Samuel Salgado tiene
la historia
[Música]
bajo una misma voz partieron cerca de
mil personas provenientes de Venezuela
Ecuador El Salvador Haití Guatemala
desde la frontera sur de México con
rumbo a Estados Unidos se trata de la
primera caravana de migrantes de este
año Kelvin Ochoa es venezolano y lleva
viajando varios meses con su esposa e
hijo por Centroamérica visiblemente
cansado y con lesiones en sus piernas
Explica las razones de su travesía
por seguir adelante
todo por ellos por ayudar también a mi
familia Dani también venezolano es
profesor el salario mensual de los
docentes venezolanos es máximo de 18
dólares un monto paupérrimo para
sobrevivir
trabajarías por vocación por enseñar por
cumplir tu rol pero por cubrir tus
necesidades básicas imposibles la
trayectoria de los migrantes venezolanos
arranca desde la frontera con Colombia
la etapa más dura es la selva del Darién
cientos mueren allí luego los esperas
Centroamérica donde también existen
peligros en Nicaragua nos acusó a la
policía de Nicaragua porque no traíamos
salvoconducto igual que ahorita y
corriendo vamos a saltar una cerca y
había un Barranco y ahí doble mi pieza
ya en México algunos migrantes llevan
salvoconductos del Instituto Nacional de
Migración pero solo les permite viajar
por el Sureño estado de Chiapas esta
primera caravana de migrantes se da dos
meses después de la nueva política
migratoria el presidente estadounidense
Joe biden que acoge mensualmente a
30.000 cubanos nicaragüenses haitianos y
venezolanos bajo estrictas condiciones y
por vía aérea por lo que los migrantes
irregulares que llegan por México corren
el riesgo de la deportación inmediata
por parte de las autoridades
estadounidenses
y en otras noticias relacionadas con
México el presidente Andrés Manuel López
Obrador acusó al departamento de estado
de Estados Unidos de injerencia en
asuntos internos tras las críticas a su
reforma electoral esto al tiempo que
aseguró que esta tendencia es contraria
a las políticas del presidente Joe
La mala costumbre siempre
te inmiscuyen
en asuntos que no les corresponden
muy contrario a lo que piensa el
presidente de
aire que siempre habla
de
igualdad la Corte Suprema de Justicia de
Estados Unidos examina el plan del
presidente Joe biden para condonar los
préstamos estudiantiles federales a
millones de estudiantes a lo largo de la
jornada los nueve jueces escucharon los
argumentos de la apelación presentada
por la administración biden contra los
dos fallos que bloquearon el proceso el
año pasado cientos de personas entre
ellas activistas y estudiantes llegaron
hasta la sede del supremo en Washington
para presionar por la medida que
aliviaría al futuro financiero de
quienes pudieron estudiar con estos
préstamos más detalles con nuestro
corresponsal en la capital
estadounidense Cristóbal Vázquez
el magistrado John Roberts y la mayoría
conservadora de la Corte Suprema de
Justicia que tiene seis de las nueve
sillas Indicó que la administración de
Joe biden violó la separación de poderes
al querer con donar cuatrocientos mil
millones de dólares de deuda estudiantil
sin la autorización del Congreso
comentario que es un revés para la
administración de Joe biden y su interés
de aliviar la deuda de más de 40
millones de estadounidenses por su parte
Elena cagan magistrada de corte liberal
argumentó que la administración de biden
actuó en respuesta de la pandemia y las
necesidades de los estadounidenses de
hecho tras la pandemia y la crisis
inflacionaria que vive el país 53% de
los prestatarios dice que la estabilidad
financiera de ellos depende del alivio
de la deuda el plan anunciado
inicialmente en agosto del 2022
cancelaría Diez mil dólares de deuda de
los préstamos estudiantiles federales
aquellos que ganan menos de 125 mil
dólares al año y hay que Resaltar que
esta deuda estudiantil asciende a uno
punto siete billones de dólares la
segunda más grande después de la deuda
hipotecaria también hay que mencionar
que la decisión final el fallo final de
la Corte Suprema de Justicia se conocerá
en junio de este año
hasta aquí este informativo Gracias por
acompañarnos
[Música]